I didn't know what they,
I'm trying to get him to rap show.
Oh,
new one.
Oh my mind just wanders.
Gentleman.
Let me give this phone to get around
this problem.
Rocket Man.
And they got me wildly,
but he didn't understand it ain't my
lady because he understood.
Okay.
So this is day three of hurricane.
No hurricane sandy aftermath.
I am up in a hotel in midtown Manhattan.
My employers and Msnbc were nice enough
to put me up,
um,
for.
I been staying in my friends up in a,
uh,
upper west side.
Great friends,
great employer.
I haven't been back to my place in like
three days.
I'm back down in lower east side,
which is,
you know,
completely without power.
It's a strange situation right now
because it's like half the city is dark
half the sit down right now in lower
Manhattan.
It is like Mad Max,
wild west style,
you know,
people in dumpsters trying to get food,
crowding around surge protectors to
charge their cell phones.
It's crazy.
Obviously the power being out is not as
bad as the way some people have a right
now,
which is,
you know,
I'm talking about the Jersey shore where
there's just scenes of devastation.
Houses are torn up,
people have unfortunately passed away in
the storm.
It's,
it's,
it's terrible.
So you really can't complain even for
what,
you know,
they have to go go through down there,
but it's still a very strange and
surreal sight,
uh,
being,
um,
being in the city and how being in a,
in a,
in a really,
what is an island divided
Friday
also.
And this,
you just don't surprise,
you don't want to do.
You made it man certain vibe you that
night to dynamite out of sight.
He doesn't Bite Nice shadow more.
I'm gonna leave,
you know,
but he's a King Ya'll queens,
right?